OF COMMERCE THAT ARE FUNDING IT.
ALSO DEPRESSING.
THAT WAS SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY’S
VIEW OF IT, GAVE A SPEECH ON THE
SENATE FLOOR TODAY EXPRESSING AS
MUCH.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE THINKING RIGHT NOW,
MR. PRESIDENT ?
THEY ARE THINKING THIS COUNTRY
WAS FOUNDED BY GENIUSES BUT IS
BEING RUN BY A BUNCH OF IDIOTS.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO LEAVE TO
OUR CHILDREN IF WE ALLOW THIS
ECONOMY TO CRASH?
>> Tucker: SENATOR KENNEDY
JOINS US TONIGHT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU’VE BEEN IN WASHINGTON FOR A
WHILE, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING REALLY LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC VERSION OF THIS BILL.
ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE A PARODY AND
I AM NOT BEING PARTISAN HERE,
BEING SINCERE.
DID THEY THINK THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE ENACTED INTO LAW?
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT MANDATING
DIVERSITY OFFICERS AND CORPORATE
AMERICA IS AN APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE TO CORONAVIRUS?
WHAT IS THIS?
>> I THINK THAT THEY THINK THAT
THEY HAVE THE REPUBLICANS OVER A
BARREL AND THE PRESIDENT.
REALITY CALLS AND CONGRESS IS
HANGING UP.
I MEANT WHAT I SAID ON THE
FLOOR, TUCKER.
FOR CHARITABLE AMERICANS ARE
THINKING OF THEMSELVES, THEY
WERE SOME GOOD MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS BUT WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY ARE GOOD FOR.
LESS CHARITABLE AMERICANS ARE
SAYING HOW DID THESE MAKE IT
THROUGH THE BIRTH CANAL.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS,
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR SAVINGS,
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR 401(K).
WE THINK WE KNOW HOW TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK ON ITS FEET OVER
THE NEXT 60 TO 90 DAYS UNTIL WE
CAN GET CONTROL OF THE VIRUS AND
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE ACTING
LIKE A HOLES.
I’M SORRY, I’M NOT SAYING THEY
MEAN TO BUT NONETHELESS, THEY
ARE KILLING IT.
THEY ARE THROWING IN EVERY
SPECIAL INTEREST POLITICAL WANT,
NOT NEED THINKING THAT THEY CAN
RAM IT THROUGH BUT BECAUSE WE
ARE TOO SCARED TO VOTE AGAINST
AND IT IS JUST WRONG.
IT’S JUST WRONG.
>> Tucker: IT IS ALSO
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
THIS ISN’T RENAMING A
POST OFFICE.
THIS IS SOMETHING OF REAL
INTEREST OF THE WHOLE COUNTRY
AND PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
DO THEY THINK NO ONE WAS GOING
TO NOTICE WHAT WAS IN THE BILL?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
I’M NOT SURE THEY ARE THINKING
AT ALL.
I SAW A PRESS CONFERENCE THE
SPEAKER AND I MEAN NO DISRESPECT
TO HER BUT BASICALLY SHE WAS
SAYING SHE WANTS PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO COME OUT AND ENDORSED
OBAMACARE.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, YOU
KNOW THAT AND I KNOW THAT.
THEY HAVE PROVISIONS, YOU DID A
GOOD JOB IN YOUR COMMENTARY.
CORPORATE BOARD DIVERSITY,
SAME-DAY ELECTION REGISTRATION,
TAX CREDITS, SOLAR TAX CREDITS.
THIS STUFF IS BASICALLY THEY
WANT THE GREEN NEW DEAL AND THEY
ARE SAYING IF YOU REPUBLICANS
DON’T ENDORSE IT, WE ARE GOING
TO STRANGLE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ECONOMICALLY.
NOW FOR SMALL SEGMENT OF OUR
POPULATION, IT’S TRUE, THE
CORONAVIRUS CAN KILL YOU.
FOR A SMALL SEGMENT BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT ELSE CAN KILL YOU?
POVERTY.
HUNGER.
WE NEED TO STOP THINKING ABOUT
THE NEXT ELECTION AND TRY TO
THINK LITTLE MORE ABOUT THE NEXT
GENERATION AND WHAT WE WILL
LEAVE TO THEM WHICH IS GOING TO
BE THE END OF NOTHING IF WE LET
THIS ECONOMY COLLAPSE.
AND IT IS AVOIDABLE.
WE CAN STAND IT BACK UP.
BUT WE DON’T HAVE MONTHS TO DO
IT.
WE’VE GOT DAYS.
>> Tucker: IT DOES FEEL LIKE
THAT, IT FEELS LIKE WE’VE GOT
DAYS, I AGREE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT AND ASSESSING THIS
ABOMINATION AND IT REALLY IS AN
ABOMINATION.